so many different types of white people
they are it makes you see the spectrum
of white and there's a guy there's a
white guy with a beer there's a lady
who's white there's a guy sweater who's
white yeah it's just such a variety
that's my favorite way right there and
there's a Jewish gentleman I assume a
rabbi who will be sacrificed it's great
to see all of them all the minorities
are are in working positions as opposed
to just being invited their security or
their I'm gonna I'm gonna stop you there
Dave if you work there you are invited a
huge day for dumb people huge day for
Russian huge day for third wives
but also you see all the elderly
Caucasian people at this event
yeah just one little last you
before they die white is back white is
back and I think as as as people who
work in the media it's our job to report
it and not worry about it yes
[Music]